[Music]
we were engaged once before so how do
you know that this time is different
yeah I've learned I was engaged before
and I've learned a ton from that
relationship I think most importantly
I've learned what I don't want in a life
partner and I really learned what I do
want and when I'm with Amanda it's a
total 180 than it was before
Josh Murray is serious with Amanda
Stanton on bachelor in paradise but
they've also dealt with questions about
Josh other cast members have brought up
his ex Andi Dorfman tell-all book and
her allegations against him it's a
fictional story have you read the book
and how did that affect your time with
Amanda no I haven't read the book at all
obviously I'm asked to do interviews and
they show me excerpts and it's like okay
I just learned something new about
myself today or this may be a little bit
of truth but it's twisted in such a way
that it becomes the worst kind of lie
possible I ended things quite a few
times with Andy for a reason and I just
hope she gets over everything and she
can be happy herself
[Music]